more you wash your face the better
oh no no no no no no no
you don't need to exfoliate
oh man oh i love this one myth
if you feel a tingling or burning
sensation it means the product is
working
oh my gosh i had to say no when i saw
this myth
my name is nikita wilson and i'm a
cosmetic chemist and my name is dr
claire chang and we're here today to
debunk a few myths about skincare
let's get started drinking extra water
will make your skin look better
ooh take it away dr chang although
drinking an
adequate amount of water is important
for your overall health there's actually
no scientific evidence that drinking
extra water goes straight to your skin
or that it can improve your skin
hydration
excess water is most likely just
filtered out of your body
i can personally attest to the extra
water just passing through
our next myth your skin will get used to
the products you use
and then they'll stop working oh i love
that one
it's not a matter of your skin getting
used to the products
a product can only do but so much there
comes a point where
those ingredients have done all they
could possibly do for your skin
if you've noticed a huge improvement
when you first started using a product
and then noticed less improvement over
time just like nikita said
it may be because over time we reach a
plateau
in which her skin's visibly improved and
at this point the ingredients are still
working but they're maintaining a new
normal the order in which you use your
skin care products
doesn't matter order definitely matters
in general
you should apply your products thinnest
to thickest and those with the active
ingredients should go on first
agree 100 if you have a water-based
serum
it's going to be hard-pressed to fight
its way through those barriers that we
created in the cream in order to get
into the skin to work
so definitely thinner more active first
and then build up heavier later so i
recommend doing a cleanser first
then a toner essences or ampoules then
do your thicker moisturizers and your
creams then your facial oils
then your sunscreen and then your makeup
our next myth is
pores can get smaller oh
no your pores do not get smaller there
is also a circulating myth going around
that cold water can shrink the pores
but this is just a myth your pores are
the same size
what can happen is your pores can swell
up
you know oil can bring dirt debris dead
skin cells can get in there and swell
they get engorged you know from all the
stuff that gets stuck in there
and then when they're cleaned out they
just get back to the normal size
but the walls can also get compromised
and so they can kind of lean
and become weak and that also could
change the appearance of how your pores
look
you don't need to moisturize your face
if it's oily this
is definitely a myth there is a
difference between skin
oil and skin hydration so skin hydration
is the water content or the moisture
levels of the skin
whereas skin oil is the sebum content so
sebum is secreted
by your facial oil glands or sebaceous
glands
and it helps protect the skin barrier
but sebum can contribute to that oily
greasy look on the face so people don't
like it
the important thing to remember is that
oily skin can become dehydrated
and have a low water content so
moisturizing is still
important i advise that you use the
right moisturizers
oil-free moisturizers that are
non-comedogenic also look for
lightweight lotions rather than thicker
creams
the lotions have a higher water to oil
content whereas creams have a
higher oil to water content most
recently i've been using sorwatu
which is a korean brand s-u-l
um w-h-a-s-o-o
you didn't know this was gonna be a
spelling bee too did you you don't need
to wear
sunscreen even when it's cloudy you need
to wear
sunscreen when it's cloudy when it's
sunny the only time you don't need to
wear sunscreen is when there is no sun
it's night just because you can't see
the sun the uv rays are still there
they're still present
and it's the uv rays that are doing the
damage and
it doesn't matter what your pigmentation
load is
you need sunscreen i recommend 30 and
above
because if you're using 15 and then
you're using a little bit
you're not going to get the level of
protection that you need the more
expensive the product the better it
works
absolutely false many of the products
that i use and that i recommend are very
affordable
and found in the drugstore i say that
the efficacy of the ingredients
and the formulation matter a lot more
than the price
i agree you know as a chemist i want you
to buy the most expensive products we
make
but the reality is it really does get
get down to the ingredients and what
you're looking for
you can go to the drugstore and you can
pick out really great
products that can really help you and
really make a difference in your
skincare
the next myth is the more you wash your
face the better
oh no no no no no no no your face is not
that dirty you know you wash it in the
morning you wash it at night you don't
have to overdo it
actually the more you wash your face
your skin could be
worse off one you are getting rid of
the microbiome you're throwing at all of
balance and when you do that you
compromise your skin barrier and when
your skin barriers compromise that can
lead to irritation
sensitivity over washing your face
especially with harsh soaps or
scrubs the ones with those beads in it
can really dry out and irritate the skin
i just recommend washing your face twice
a day and then also
after sweating heavily because sweat can
clog the pores
and irritate the skin further you don't
need to exfoliate
oh man everyone can benefit from some
gentle exfoliation
exfoliating can help renew and brighten
your skin
even your skin tone declog pores
it helps in anti-aging and it can
actually
improve the absorption of other topicals
you're putting on your skin
i love exfoliation i love it for every
reason you just named
and for me again because i have very
oily skin and acne prone
and also hyperpigmentation exfoliation
really helps
you're reminding me i need to go
exfoliate today
if you're using a very gentle exfoliant
you can do it every day
if you tend to have sensitive skin and
you're
or you're using a higher concentration
you might want to limit it
to two times a week even one time a week
and then if you're using in office kind
of chemical peels and going to a facial
list or your dermatologist
you may want to limit it to every two to
four weeks because they're using much
higher concentrations of
chemical exfoliants i can't end this
without giving a shout out to dr
uh dennis gross in his aha bha pad
beautiful beautiful the next
myth is you need to use a lot of
skincare products to get good skin
again as a cosmetic chemist i wish that
were true
you don't need to use a lot of products
you just need to find the right products
to work for
your skin needs sometimes actually using
too many products can do more
harm than good oh i love this one
myth if you feel a tingling or burning
sensation
it means the product is working i had to
say
no when i saw this myth i was just like
oh i always say
actually your daily skincare should
typically not be uncomfortable at
all and if it is it's a sign that your
skin cannot tolerate the product
it's not always good to ask someone what
are you using and then go and buy it
because your skin may not have the same
tolerance level
as there so you may have a different
reaction and i know a lot of people
who try to use the best the most
effective ingredient
and they try to kind of stand through it
they want to persist because
they want to get their skin looking
shiny and
wrinkle free but your skin again is
different from all of those people out
there and it may not be able to tolerate
it
so you want to find the right product
for you
acne is only a problem during puberty
can someone sell my skin that please you
could have not had
acne during puberty and all of a sudden
as you
enter 30s or 40s you all of a sudden
start to get it you know your hormones
are changing
and i'm a living breathing testament
that that is not the case adult acne may
be persistent from puberty but a lot of
times it's late onset in patients who've
never had acne before the reasons for
acne
in adulthood are genetics hormones
clogged pores inflammation stress can
definitely worsen acne
certain diets can worsen acne including
you know high sugar
high carb diet pregnancy can sometimes
trigger
acne i definitely had acne during my
pregnancy
cosmetics too it's nice to really kind
of localize where the acne is
because those might be triggers that you
can remove
and see if your acne gets better by
removing those triggers
you just want to be patient with it
remember that any treatment for acne can
take six to eight weeks to work
so you just really want to stick to it
unless of course you're getting that
burning tingling or irritation from it
dark
under eye circles are always due to a
lack of sleep they can be actually due
to
a lot of different issues and everyone's
different
so sometimes it's due to lack of sleep
and puffy eyes
in other patients it might be due to you
ate a salty meal
the night before or had some alcohol and
it's causing
swelling but also maybe due to genetics
a lot of patients have
dark under eye circles even since they
were younger allergies can also cause
dark under eye circles so
if your eyes are itchy and you're
rubbing it all the time
or as we all mature we lose fat
in our cheeks and our under eye area and
that can create a contrast
and a shadowing effect knowing the cause
really is the key to finding the best
way to go about treating it
the next myth is you shouldn't use eye
creams unless you have wrinkles
no actually i know a lot of younger
people who are using eye creams
as more of a preventative measure
because they're trying to prevent their
skin from drying out they're trying to
keep the skin
elastic nikita i think you said it
beautifully prevention
is key in skincare and the eye area is
often the first
area to show signs of aging actually
late 20s early 30s is when you start
losing collagen
i have to go tell my daughters to start
using a cream
[Laughter]
serums and oils are a waste of money
no serums are actually what i spend the
most money on
serums are highly concentrated with
active ingredients
like antioxidants and hydrating factors
that really benefit your skin
serums are really are what's doing the
brunt of the work
agree 100 you can budget your cleanser
you can budget your moisturizer and even
your sunscreen
but where you should think about
spending the bulk of your budget
should be on the thing that's going to
give you the biggest treatment and
that's the serum
there's a huge range of skin issues that
serums can really help with
you can get rid of dark spots i do this
every day at work
it takes time it takes discipline
and it takes you truly truly being
committed to
understanding the source and why you're
getting your dark spots
dark spots often have a component of
deeper pigment in the skin
and that's where laser treatments come
in brown spots can always come back
and you can get new bronze spots so
sunscreen is the most important thing
you can do
to help prevent and treat dark spots
one thing about skin of color is we were
always told that you know lasers
are not good for our skin because it'll
end up causing more dark spots have they
improved the technology now where
somebody like me can come to you and say
hey dr chang how about these spots it is
true
that skin of color is a little bit more
sensitive to laser and the reason
is that there is more pigment in
patients and skin of color or darker
skin tones
there are resurfacing lasers that are
lower in energy and gentle
but can help improve brown spots over a
series of treatments
i'll make an appointment with you as
soon as we wrap this up
what do we have here losing weight will
help get rid of my cellulite
oh so cellulite it's one of the most
common complaints i see
but one of the most difficult to treat
you have to remember that cellulite
is not just a condition of excess fat or
being out of shape
and in fact i see cellulite in all
weight groups we don't know exactly what
causes cellulite
but it can be associated with genetics
hormones and then lifestyle can also
play a key component
on a more biologic level cellulite is
due to poor circulation
it's due to inflammation so again a lot
of reasons why people get cellulite
physical activity may actually help a
little bit with cellulite by increasing
circulation and blood flow
but weight loss in and of itself may not
improve your cellulite
when it comes to the beauty industry and
products to solve it there's no
silver bullet in a cream or serum and
give to you
and i've seen some of the most in shape
women have cellulite
if you don't get eczema as a kid you
won't get it as an adult
i don't believe that to be true
i actually just saw several cases of new
adult eczema patients this past week so
it's very common
eczema is especially common in adults
who actually have work related contacts
so
health care workers construction workers
or hairdressers who
wash their hands frequently or come into
contact with a lot of chemicals
eczema is managed primarily by a really
good skincare routine
dry irritated skin can make you more
prone to eczema
so you want to make sure you're
hydrating and moisturizing very
frequently
k-beauty only works for east asian
customers
that's not how skin works k-beauty is
definitely not
just for asian skin you have to keep in
mind that in terms of ethnicity
though there are slight differences in
terms of pigmentation
and moisture levels between ethnic
groups the basic structure of the skin
and the aging processes that the skin
goes through
is essentially the same no matter what
your ethnicity differences in distinct
skin types oily skin versus dry skin
versus sensitive skin
is likely more significant than
ethnicity when it comes to skin care
i created my products and i was looking
at certain things
like i know in black skin the level of
ceramides is lower than in any skin
types so i include ceramides
overall anybody can use the product if
your skin doesn't need it it won't use
it if there's one thing people should
take away from
all these myths is just know your skin i
believe in having a relationship with
your skin you know you're in a
relationship with another person
you know what makes them happy you know
how to push their buttons
have that same relationship with your
skin and then a lot of these things
you won't have to rely on you will know
what works for your skin be patient
skincare always takes time
and if you have any questions feel free
to reach out ask your dermatologist or
ask your physician
really just choose a good skincare
routine that will take you over long
term
and work well with your skin